at least five people dead another 48
injured after a man drove his suv into a
christmas parade the man had a long
criminal record drugs
battery domestic abuse he was charged
just last july with two counts of
reckless endangerment and possession of
a dangerous weapon as a convicted felon
but he was released on 500 bail last
february then he was charged again just
a couple of weeks ago with resisting or
obstructing an officer bail jumping
recklessly endangering safety disorderly
conduct and battery connected to
domestic abuse
then
he was released just six days after that
on a thousand dollar bond then he struck
again
now five people are dead
dozens are injured the
criminal who killed those people and
injured so many more people was out on
on a thousand dollar bond he he
shouldn't have been out on the bond
obviously he shouldn't have been out
even the last time because he got out on
a bail for the last charges he's a
career criminal he's a thug he should
have been rotting away in prison but
we have calls for
criminal justice reform we have calls
for leniency we have calls openly to
abolish prisons
and we're told this is compassionate
it's very wrong to lock up dangerous
criminals it's it's wrong and it's
racist somehow and it's and it's
mean-spirited and it's cruel and so
we've got to let them out and because
the compassionate thing is to let five
people be struck by an issue well i'm
sorry dozens of people struck by an suv
five killed and many many more injured
even the d.a in milwaukee county john
chisholm now admits the bail was a
little too low they were a little too
compassionate don't you think
quote the state's bail recommendation in
this case was inappropriately low
in light of the nature of the recent
charges and the pending charges against
this guy
says john chisholm the milwaukee d.a
whoopsy daisy
yep oops it was a little too low ah
yeah maybe it should have been two
thousand dollars oops whoopsie
uh that's it that's it that now
no i don't i don't think that's it i
think that first of all this guy john
chisholm should resign
or should be chased out of office
and i think that we need to take a
moment here and pause and figure out
what got us into this mess in the first
place i'm not just throwing blame on
everyone obviously the guy who drove the
suv is the person primarily at fault
here he's the one who committed the
crime
but how was he permitted to commit that
crime
through gross negligence
through criminal negligence if you ask
me of our law enforcement of our really
of our elected officials
and and of the people of milwaukee who
voted for these people and who voted for
this kind of stuff criminal justice
reform
we've got to be compassionate it's not
even just democrats i want to i want to
do my best to mitigate scapegoating the
left here and scapegoating the democrats
the republicans did this too trump
peddled this stuff you know i love trump
i voted for trump twice big supporter of
trump but he peddled this stuff remember
the first step act
which i referred to at the time and
still do as the jailbreak bill we were
told it's somehow deeply conservative to
spring criminals from the clink
how is that conservative
even the republicans even right-wing
conservative republicans bought into
this lie that we have an
over-incarceration problem in the united
states we got crime spiking crime is
going through the roof especially
violent crime
up to and including murders
but obviously we don't have an
over-incarceration problem we have an
under-incarceration problem
when crime's gone up you have an
under-incarceration problem okay hold up
stop collaborate and listen collaborate
with me please by ringing that bell
subscribe you'll get notifications and
if our
big tech friends don't send you
notifications i would really recommend
you head on over to apple podcast spot
if i stitch your google play subscribe
to the audio podcast michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you